you've ever had someone near Twitter
mentions with a stuck caps lock and
broken spellcheck encouraging you to
quote eat a breakfast burrito made of
cat turds then chances are this was
their avatar the Twitter egg has long
been the official mascot of abusive
trolls with low follower counts who
according to them spend most of their
time plowing all our moms what a service
they do to all of us thank you so much
for all the mom plowing well now
Twitter's retiring the egg avatar
replacing it with this a gender-neutral
box headed blob who in fact fun fact
modeled after pitbull not sure if you
guys
every time the song plays a 20 year old
in Tampa becomes the grandmother so
comedians now the Twitter has no more
use for them what do we do with all
these hostile trolling eggs Rhett Miller
use them to make a douche quiche yes
very good boy mother Joe to make a
really racist omelet that asked female
celebrities for pictures of their feet
at random the morning protein you need
for a full day of doctoring women who
have opinions about video games oh very
good